das geht laut entwickler und zu einer
runde crazy world zusammen mit zum
waffel und diese vielleicht schon ich
bin jetzt hier mit einem diamond mit
einer diamond pigs gestartet war ich
habe mir so ein cooles kita projekt
gekauft und wir haben schon beschriebene
richtig krank runde gespielt richtig die
kugel checkt die auf jeden fall aus
linken beschreibt vision bis 5 wasser
knapp 150 was schafft es auch richtig
dass fünf schwert also komplett
feierabend und wir streben natürlich
nach nichts geringerem als der
nachahmung dieser wunderbaren runde ist
immer dabei ich glaube wir probiert
rekorde haben wir letztes mal so dann
noch zwei minuten zeit einfach mal
irgendwann weil wir alles so schnell
abgebaut hat ja darum geht es jetzt
natürlich auch heute wieder nicht
du bist du richtig pokern ist secret
voyage es natürlich wieder nur knapp
drin ist wie immer aber irgendwie dieser
spielmodus macht es extrem viel spaß und
ich finde das ist ja auf jeden fall
finde es cool dass man denn auch so
crazy upgraden kann komplett durch drei
minuten
nein nicht so ärzte haben wir irgendwie
ein abgang verpasst des wertes zu krank
jetzt schon durch zu sein wie viel gold
hat ihren 13
dann kann's halt echt hinkommen läuft
bei uns
und das hier ist einfach mal
wir sind einfach zu schnell so dann kann
man gleich wieder 35
warten wir einfach wieder ich habe schon
fünf von acht haben wir jetzt
mittlerweile schon die anderen sind alle
noch secret unter der erde glaube ich
mal zwei gehörende erde dann lars
protection ist das ein schlechter
verzauberung ich bin der wohl also ich
hab hier noch gold und links will ich ja
je nachdem so thema aufnahme die
maschine maschine so da kam bogen raus
nein aber ich befürchte fast ein
emirates habe ich einen genug weil ich
ja schon am atmen erschwert hat ich
befürchte mir fehlt noch ein gold bis
ich meinen experten
u
er ist wirklich sehr weil ohne die
us-staaten fühlt sich einfach nicht
richtig
wir haben halt auch einfach wie wir
haben wir fünf stück und diesen geheimen
kisten dinge wir haben 50 66 oder text
von aber ich glaube schon direkt und 12
vielleicht also ich mir noch was zum
chillen oder so ich glaube ich kann
ersten bogens der gewinner bekommt
ich habe aber auch schon ein aspekt
einer v2 bogen outtara goldner ich habe
mir noch gar nicht gekauft
also ich kaufe mir einfach nur ein weg
den ihr das hier und es macht aber
irgendwie spaß wenn man so produktiv ist
am anfang jetzt hat mit einem 1 minute
und irgendwie noch habe ich hier noch
räumen findet ihr auch unter der erde ob
man die anderen beiden haben auf dem
buckel
wie soll den direkt durch die wand
gegeben
die krasseste service sehen würde ich
sagen
damit sehen will okay aber kannst mir
noch nicht so schnell geben
kannst du mir einen gold apfel droppen
dann können wir einfach lecker wo sind
unsere aggressiven gegner
das waren die hinter der roten wand die
kommen nicht aber wir gehen direkt auf
die grünen welche direkt stürmen gehen
leicht an lang glaubt ganz gut durch
meister sogar drin war sehr schön sehr
schön sehr schnell löschen
interessen wie diese mit dem skaten loos
l jetzt auch alleine
der arme ist der download oder
interessiert ist kann es sein dass
mindestens für andere und ich muss ein
bisschen defensiv spielen gegen direkte
weg weg weg weg wenn ich bin in der
höhle eineinhalb herzen hatte dass du
ein komplett frischer noch keiner rennt
mir hinterher gehöre nicht gegeben
richtig martin jetzt habe ich arbeite
als ort oder drei sogar drei fürs team
hinter mir weggeholt müssten jetzt alle
durch sein zumindest ich hab ein paar
player köpfen und kommst du nach oben
wieder erwartet
wir brauchen player hätte auch richtig
zerpflückt alter ich bin offen ja ich
habe zwei player jetzt glaube ich schon
mal kurz machen wir einmal aufklappen
einmal auf knapp 13 machen
ramsbeck extrem stark schon wieder von
einer amok wird ein - renault sind bei
uns noch gegner in den grün-weißen
hierbei wir sind sogar noch einen link
noch ein player hat glaube ich weil ich
drei leute gerade gepflückt nicht ich
hab auch wieder nur dieses an breaking
scheiß also mit gleich selber man 12 ich
weiß gar nicht ob noch jemand hier bei
uns am leben ist übrigens in der
fraktion wird man nicht alle durch ko xp
fläschchen vielleicht war aber okay die
restlichen gar nicht gegeben alles gute
für mich perfekt schaffen es 34 aspect 1
statt die logik stabiler kopf ist bei
mir selber versteht nicht dass sie dich
wieder angreifen
glücklich weil ich habe aber auch noch
ein player hätten nach wie vor warum man
sich hier nämlich einmal mama achtung
networks von rechtsrock morath erobert
ich hab noch aber ich hab noch aber
nicht ich gehe nicht alleine schon
gelandet
der typ 2 rose der auf 330 denken das
mitdenken kredite kriegen wie riesig
über diesen geist alter nur architekt
ein player hat steht die ach so ich dir
alles gut also ich habe drei stück ich
hatte drei stück nur durch ok gerne so
ich habe auch zwei protection weise ja
also wer nicht sagen aber so wird's halt
einfach gespielt so wie viele teams
leben noch sechs stück das heißt können
ordentlich ordentlich schnee soll jetzt
schon von skills läuft nur bis auf den
kopf hat ob frau stark
so wirst du immer noch im keller hat
jetzt können wir gehen auf die auf die
hand ich dachte du hättest noch ein
aber du hast echt krank wie der 5 wo
sind die gegner sind die gegner nach
moment das hat doch die in der mitte
hier würde lässt alles aktivieren
solange ich da sein können uns wieder so
richtig ranken ps holen
noch besser gerade ernsthaft das tik tok
beck 51 krankheit ist das neu
wenn ich bei bruce aber keine ahnung wer
noch ein los gibt uns europäisch heißt
aber nur drei gegner alter das glaubt
die schnellste crazy ist überhaupt die
drei gegner
okay da vorne ist einer hinten mir
hinterher der versteckt sich weil wir
wegrennen einfach auf jeden fall oder
getroffen hallo du hast schon wieder an
der mittellinie
also ich bin einfach in der mitte was
mich brauchst speedport die bald zeigen
dass man mit dem kompass ich hab den weg
ich kann ich keine abmahnung wir denken
wir finden einfach mit rein
zweite wurde alte okay okay
sie sind aber auch nicht mehr obwohl
doch diesem kraftvoll what the [ __ ]
alter what the [ __ ] da war ich aber der
mich in die prüfer reinalter hatte so
viele sachen also ich hab vor den altar
fucking verwalter
wir wissen direkt nur bisher wissen die
im global compact nicht sicher komm ich
jetzt noch als ob was geht ab da habe
ich ein für mich sicher nicht auf jeden
fall ein gut gedämmtes respekt oder oder
kritik nicht klappt eigentlich noch hier
aber dir aus dass der andere direkt als
herren rennen rennen rennen rennen
rennen rennen okay ich hab noch ein
zweiter diese explodiert er nicht doha
dina4 to become exclusive ich hatte noch
den explosiven okay es war krank auf
jeden fall auf crazy tin am ende noch
mal größere auswahl richtig richtig
heftig runde ich hab's ja nicht gefallen
wenn ihr noch eine weitere heftige runde
sehen wollt sturm war fällt und dann bis
zum nächsten mal macht's gut